قال وزير الخارجيه البريطاني ديفيد
كاميرون ان لندن تدرس الاعتراف بالدوله
الفلسطينيه واضاف كاميرون ان بلاده ستنظر
مع حلفائها مساله الاعتراف بالدوله
الفلسطينيه بما في ذلك في الامم المتحده
واشار الى ان المملكه المتحده تتحمل
مسؤوليه تحديد الشكل الذي ستبدو عليه
الدوله الفلسطينيه واكد وزير الخارجيه
البريطاني انه يجب ان يظهر للشعب
الفلسطيني تقد لا رجعه فيه نحو حل
الدولتين ولفت الى انه يجب منح
الفلسطينيين افقا سياسيا لتشجيع السلام في
الشرق
الاوسط معنا من لندن مراسلتنا مينا حربلو
مينا اهلا بك السياقات التي جاء فيها هذا
الكلام لوزير الخارجيه ديفيد كاميرون
دلالته في هذا التوقيت
ايضا
نعم وزير الخارجيه البريطاني ديفيد كامرون
يبدا اليوم رحله هي الرابعه منذ توليه هذا
المنصب في وزاره الخارجيه البريطانيه الى
منطقه الشرق الاوسط تحت
عنوان يعني دعم الجهود لاحلال الاستقرار
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط بما في ذلك التعامل
مع قضيه الهجمات التي يشنها انصار الله
الحوثيين على السفن التجاريه اضافه الى
الاهم من ذلك هو قضيه انهاء هذا النزاع
الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني بما في ذلك وقف
الحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه الوزير
كان يتحدث ليله امس في وقت متاخر في مجلس
امام مجلس حزب المحافظين للشؤون الخارجيه
الذي حضره
ايضا سفراء من الدول العربيه حين قال بان
بريطانيا مستعده لتقديم ما وصفها باللحظه
للاعتراف رسميا بالدوله الفلسطينيه وقال
بان على الفلسطينيين الفلسطينيين ان يروا
ان يظهر لهم العالم بان هناك افقا سياسيا
يمكن يعني التعامل معه للوصول الى حل
الدولتين ايمانا منه ومن من الحكومه
البريطانيه بان حل الدولتين اسرائيل تعيش
الى جانب دوله فلسطينيه مستقله في
المستقبل مازال ممكنا سيكون صعبا لكنه في
اعتقاده ليس مستحيلا الوزير كان يقول بان
بريطانيا مستعده اعتراف بهذه الدوله
الفلسطينيه المستقله في حين يمكن اثناء
التفاوض مع الشركاء وجراء هذه المفاوضات
التي في هذه الزياره هي جزء من اجراء هذه
المفاوضات يمكن لبريطانيا بان تبحث مع
الحلفاء بالاعتراف رسميا بالدوله
الفلسطينيه بما في ذلك في الامم المتحده
لان ذلك في اعتقاده سيكون من احد الاشياء
الاشياء التي ستجعل هذه العمليه لا رجعه
فيها بحيث تلتزم الاطراف المعنيه بهذا
بهذه القضيه وزير الخارجيه يقول بان
بريطانيا تؤمن بحل الدولتين ولا تزال تصر
على ان ذلك ممكن في المقابل يقول بانه يجب
ان تكون تحدث هناك يعني ظروف معينه بما في
ذلك دوله دوله فلس حكومه فلسطينيه مكونه
من تكنوقراط جيدين بحسب تعبيره للتمكن من
حكم قطاع غزه وايضا يتعين على اسرائيل
اطلاق سراح جميع الرهائن الفلسطينيين
لديها وايضا بان تغادر حركه حماس ومجموع
عناصر
حماش قطاع غزه بالكامل هذه الشروط التي
وضعتها بريطانيا ووزير رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني نفسه كان قد تحدث عن شروط خمس
لاحلال هذه العمليه عمليه السلام انطلاقا
من هدنه انسانيه لادخال المساعدات يمكن ان
تفضي الى اطلاق نار مستدام حسب تعبير
السياسيين والحكومه البريطانيه هنا يفضي
الى حل الدولتين بريطانيه لا تزال تعتقد
بان ذلك ممكن كنا سالنا وزراء معينين في
الخارجيه البريطانيه في ظل ما يجري الان
في قطاع غزه من عمليه توصف بالعباده
الجماعيه للفلسطيني وعمليه النزوح
والترحيل القصري للف الفلسطينيين من قطاع
غزه عما اذا كان وما يجري ايضا في الضفه
الغربيه عما اذا كانت هذه الظروف امام هذه
الظروف المتشائمه امكانيه لاحلال دوله
فلسطينيه اقامه دوله فلسطينيه مستقله عن
اسرائيل يؤكدون لنا بان ذلك ليس مستحيلا
لكنه سيكون صعبا للغايه مينا حربلو من
لندن شكرا جزيلا لك